The Internet, as we know it today, is an outstanding success.
More than 1.3 billion people are connected to the Web across the globe.
The development is driven by users as well as by technology.
Whilst the number of users and the amount of content is growing faster and faster,...
...the Internet is departing from computers.
More than 1 billion users of mobile phones already have the opportunity to access the Internet.
Consumers will depend entirely upon network services...
...and businesses will depend entirely upon the future Internet to provide these services.
But since the current Internet consists of mostly unstructured data and resources,...
...most of the data and resources are unusable for the average user.
Fact is, the Internet is broken. We still have not one Web,...
...but a vast variety of different unlinked data that is unable to communicate.
That's why future Internet will have to change, and change it will.
We are currently rethinking the Web on various levels.
We are preparing for a web of things.
All electronic devices will be active participants in the future Internet.
Everything and everybody will be connected.
The future Internet will also reorganize publicity, privacy and anonymity....
...where everybody can understand how much trust can and should be extended to others.
Everything, everywhere, always.
We must imagine future Internet as a service.
Mobile, ubiquitous and pervasive. Twenty-four seven availability will be the norm.
To sustain the demands of the future Internet, networks must be re-engineered.
We need new networks which integrate all kinds of devices...
...and which allow the most auspicious vision of future Internet.
The Internet of services will bring an enormous increase in the efficiency of economic processes.
Business processes are unified in services that can be used by different groups of people.
Within a company or enterprise or externally, via the Internet of services.
Soon, redundantly providing the same information again and again will no longer be necessary.
Semantics will provide secure and efficient access to a coordinated set of services...
...that are not location dependent, are interoperable, coherent,...
...consistent, scalable, pervasive, and reliable.
These services will be networked together through the future Internet.